[Music]
two and a half years ago one of the most
legendary video game characters in pop
culture made his big screen debut sonic
the hedgehog since the blue hedgehog
wearing sneakers is already running
towards his third movie appearance it's
about time to present you an original
about sonic the hedgehog 3. in this
original episode you will learn
everything about cast crew production
and theories regarding the plot which so
far is still largely unknown before we
start we would like to point out that
there is an imminent risk of spoilers
for sonic the hedgehog one and two and
wish you lots of fun with our new video
before moving on to the potential
storyline of part three after the events
of 2020 sonic the hedgehog the world is
all right for sonic maddie and tom for
the moment as dr robotnik has been
banished to a distant mushroom-like
planet through a portal ring a few
months pass and sonic now tries to make
himself useful to the citizens with his
superhero powers before tom and maddie
fly to hawaii to attend the wedding of
maddie's sister and leave sonic alone
there is a piece of advice from tom to
sonic he should have patience after all
his powers would be needed sooner or
later and as if tom had guessed it
shortly after saying goodbye to his
foster parents sonic is attacked by the
returned robotnik and his new ally this
is knuckles who driven by the search for
the master emerald has sided with
robotnik except for him all the members
of his echidna tribe are extinct thus he
sees it as his calling to come into
possession of this ancient and powerful
relic fortunately sonic is rescued by
his friend miles prower alias tales and
manages to escape from robotnik's
clutches the two end up staying with
wade who happens to be a good friend and
colleague of tom they try to figure out
why exactly sonic is supposed to be the
key to the powerful master emerald
eventually sonic manages to convince
tails to track down the mysterious relic
which is far too powerful to fall into
wrong hands in parallel robotnik
contacts his assistant agent stone who
all this time was under the belief that
robotnik was dead likewise robotnik sets
out to find the emerald but of course
not to help knuckles but to claim the
stone's power for himself thanks to an
old map from sonic's mentor longclaw and
a compass the heroes get even closer to
the emerald however they are eventually
located by both robotnik and knuckles
and swept away by an avalanche sonic
succeeds in contacting tom in time and
so the two of them are saved at the very
last second by a portal ring in doing so
they burst into the midst of the wedding
ceremony which is not only embarrassing
but actually very dangerous it turns out
that not only the guests but also
rachel's fiancee are in truth undercover
agents of the gun they temporarily
arrest sonic tails and tom before they
can finally be freed by the heroic
efforts of maddie in the meantime
robotnik and knuckles find the emerald
in an underwater temple where the two
finally face off again during the combat
robotnik secretly escapes with the
emerald and absorbs its power now
knuckles also realizes that he was only
being used by robotnik and so from now
on he joined sonic and tales in the
fight against the evil doctor he has
meanwhile created a giant robot and is
destroying green hills the trio manages
to get the master emerald back although
it shatters into the seven chaos
emeralds after sonic through his new
form as supersonic is able to destroy
the robot and apparently robotnik as
well knuckles reassembles the seven
stones into one and the three new
friends live happily ever after in the
home of tom and maddie in a mid-credits
scene it is then revealed that robotnik
has disappeared without a trace the gun
encounters the secret project shadow and
the last thing we see is a black
hedgehog awakening in a research
facility
now that the main points of sonic the
hedgehog 2 have been summed up it is
time to turn our attention to the
follow-up in part three the sequel was
already confirmed in february which is
why the preparations should be in full
swing the starting point is clear we
have a trio of sonic tails and knuckles
and a disappear dr robotnik who
certainly has some things to sort out
with the three of them in the following
we introduce you to the most popular
theories on how sonic the hedgehog 3
could continue
as was already hard to miss in the
second part we will meet shadow the
hedgehog as the antagonist in the
upcoming movie as we already know thanks
to a statement from director jeff fowler
the timeline of the movies is not based
on the original sequence of the games in
terms of shadow this means that we will
quite likely get to know the story of
the gloomy character in more detail and
also delve a bit deeper into the overall
narrative of the sonic franchise that
would also mean that at least in
flashbacks we get to meet robotnik's
grandfather gerald and his granddaughter
maria the granddaughter is by the way
one of the few people shadow is not
hostile to but let's go back to the
beginning shadow originates from the
already mentioned project shadow which
was carried out about 50 years before
the events of sonic the hedgehog 2 in
the games this is a research program of
the united federation which is modeled
on today's united states and is the home
country of the military organization gun
the final product of this experiment
which was led by gerald are two
creatures that are almost immortal bio
lizard and shadow the hedgehog however
after the creation of shadow the same
name project was scrapped due to its
dangerous nature attempting to free
shadow maria robotnik was shot by a gun
soldier which in turn led her
grandfather gerald to become a villain
who sought to destroy the world for
revenge he was ultimately executed on
prison island though before doing so he
implanted his quest for revenge into
shadow the hedgehog as a result once
shadow was awakened the world
destruction plan that was programmed
into him begins to take its course at
this point we are just at the end of
sonic the hedgehog 2 and so the theory
that shadow will be the main antagonist
of the third movie is considered very
feasible
as we have unfortunately known for some
months jim carrey is left acting at the
age of almost 60. how final this
decision ultimately is cannot be said at
the moment but one thing is clear his
retirement from acting is probably a bad
omen for a sonic the hedgehog 3 which is
probably already in pre-production so
the question must be asked how to
replace the actor who for many carried
the film with his inimitable style a
popular theory has gained momentum since
the news of his end of acting and that
is one that favors an appearance by
metal sonic in the upcoming blockbuster
in short metal sonic is robotnik's
attempt to transfer sonic's powers into
a machine or rather a robot which he
succeeded in doing quite well thus he is
more or less a copy of the real sonic
only without the many human attributes
in addition metal sonic is definitely
one of sonic's strongest opponents and
unlike shadow who sometimes does show
human emotions he has a very clear and
personal goal to kill sonic therefore he
is a vicious adversary who as one of
robotnik's strongest creations does
credit to his inventor and could
worthily represent him in part three
besides knuckles and tails a character
from the games that is at least as well
known is amy rose she is not a villain
but rather a cheerful positive and
energetic hedgehog girl who has a crush
on sonic the first hints of her
appearance in sonic 3 came during a q a
with screenwriters patrick casey and
josh miller at the end of may there they
did not deny amy's presence as a popular
character in the third part and instead
they very openly stated that her
appearance was in the works it is
understandable that they were not able
to reveal much a few weeks after the
release of sonic the hedgehog 2 however
it is at least encouraging that there is
a chance of an appearance in the future
even though she sometimes has quite the
mood swings and is downright obsessed
with her great love sonic she would
surely energetically support the current
trio in the fight against shadow and the
likes despite her often innocent nature
she is quite the powerful ally who can
match her friends for example her main
weapon is the pico pico hammer which amy
uses to defend herself and which gets
bigger when she is angry
there is still little information about
the cast in production the return of ben
schwartz's sonic collino shaughnessy as
tails and idris elba as knuckles is
considered certain regarding jim carrey
as dr robotnik there is no reliable
information however many claim that he
will eventually take on the third part
while others take his departure from
acting as serious one thing is for sure
there will be no recasting of his
character under any circumstances as
producers toby asher and neil h moritz
have already pointed out it would also
be more than foolish to attempt to
recasting as it would cause a gigantic
[ __ ] storm instead several human actors
will almost certainly return including
james marsden and tikka sumter as tom
and maddie adam pally is wade whipple
and limash dube as a submissive robotnik
ally asian stone since the gun will
probably be playing a big role again we
can also imagine a return of tom butler
as commander walters shimar more as an
undercover agent and pseudohusband
randall and natasha rothwell is maddie's
sister rachel what remains even more
exciting is the casting of amy and
shadow whose appearances are more or
less assured the release date of the
animated spectacle was only recently
announced sonic the hedgehog 3 will hit
theaters in the us on december 20th 2024
and that's it for our original episode
how did you picture the upcoming sonic
the hedgehog 3 and which characters and
plot lines would you incorporate as a
scriptwriter feel free to let us know in
the comments
[Music]
you